we have other things in common which
will drive our listeners even more
insane we're both uh history Buffs and
then when you get into the Civil War it
can get a little intense uh you're yeah
was that some was that a passion when
you were young I well so I grew up in
Atlanta and and it's just kind of uh
around you a lot like they're oh yeah
you grew up in the in in a place like
Atlanta there were so many
um markers and and you we would
literally find musket balls like in the
in the yard or like weird artifacts here
and there
um and uh yeah battles all over the
place and uh and my dad had a whole
shelf of books on Civil War history and
and it just was it was a you know most
most history about conflict about wars
was so abstract but but for some reason
the Civil War being in the South it was
like I could read about places that I
knew like places that I had visited or
places that where I had like gone to
summer camp or different and these
battles were just wild and it's just you
know as I got older
and understood the context more like
it's it's such a
it's such a profoundly tragic war on so
many so many levels yes yeah and uh and
and there's just not they're not a lot
of things quite like it in in in the
history of well also at the time
especially no one had ever seen a war
like that before I mean Europeans uh you
know people from Britain and France were
coming over just to observe because
uh is that true oh yeah they were
because uh uh a war on this scale using
what at the time was this new technology
relatively new technology uh you know
that things have become so sophisticated
and there are iron clads and yeah you
know uh massive uh shells being invented
and um and the armies are huge the
armies are just massive the army of
Northern Virginia is huge the
um you know uh uh the
um northern Army is massive
um I mean the Potomac and it's so
nothing like that had happened before
and then uh on that scale and so
obviously as you know the casualties
were huge and I would just think growing
up in the South I was always fascinated
by the south and of course I grew up in
Massachusetts so we had Revolutionary
War stuff no I could go out to Lexington
and Concord and and and I and I I feel
it there too and my sister lives in in
your hometown of Brookline
and it's that it feels so visceral the
Revolutionary War feels so present there
I don't know maybe you and I just have
like a antenna for it it's funny if you
grew up in Massachusetts that's the war
you talk about but if you go down south
and have driven around Georgia
um you can pass through Andersonville
and know that like oh there was a you
know shortly after my marriage I tried
to take my wife on a I took my wife on a
trip through Georgia and I kept saying
and and we visited all these Civil War
sites and then I said now we're off to
Andersonville and she said what's that
and I said it's the prisoner of war camp
where tens of thousands of people died
of diarrhea and you're still married
yeah yeah trust me trust me that did not
happen we went she said no we're not
doing that and I said but I'm telling
you we've got to go and you couldn't
even say dysentery you had to say
diarrhea
diarrhea and then uh she said no we're
going back to Atlanta we've seen the
other stuff I've been in a good sport
but we're not looking at the diarrhea
fields and so
yeah we went back and this was my fun
story we pulled into Atlanta and we go
into our hotel and we're sitting in the
lobby of the hotel and a waiter comes
over and hands us each an Appletini and
these new slice glasses and we didn't
order these and we said
we didn't order these appletinis and he
went compliments of Mr Barkley and
Charles Barkley was at the bar and I had
never had an Appletini before but I did
go up to him and say uh Sir Charles uh
why the Appletini was he said you look
like a guy who would drink an apple tea
needless to say I love Atlanta I really
do that was fantastic